[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
hello everybody and welcome to the iron
lords podcast first look at a game
called
unto the end now onto the end is
a game where you end up playing as this
father who is looking to get back to his
family
now i ended up playing this game in its
entirety and i found it
fantastic i recommend that everyone goes
out and plays it
buys it download it on game pass first
of all hands down i will tell you that
right now
uh but i want you to keep listening and
keep watching the rest of the video just
so you have a little context
what i'm telling you to get into now
unto the end
is a game made by two ton
studios uh which is a husband and wife
team who we have had on the show before
and we have spoken to them in depthly
but i wanted to make sure that i gave
them
the proper visuals of
their game according to us here at the
podcast and i recommend that
everybody goes out and picks this up now
the graphics on it are very very
amazingly done the side scrolling aspect
looks beautiful the
i would say the clean cut type
corners edges the beautiful combat
system
now the combat now i want to talk take a
quick second to talk to you guys
about the combat the system now the
combat system
you play as you know your your main
character
and you're going to end up being able to
do your high attacks and your low
attacks
and you're also going to have a ranged
attack now the thing that makes this
interesting is that
when you're fighting other creatures
they have patterns that they're going to
be able to fight you with
so in instance they'll do two attacks
high one attack low or one attack high
one low
or too high and that's it and then too
low and then that's it
so you have to eventually learn how to
get through
all of these types of patterns to
continue throughout the game
now what i really really really loved
about this game was
there is different outcomes with certain
scenarios throughout the whole entire
game
now if you end up finding someone i'm
going to give you the
prime example is right in the beginning
you're going to find somebody in the
beginning
where you're going to need a key from
them and what you're going to end up
having to do is you're going to have to
either give them medicine or you have to
kill them and take the key
so doing one thing which is going to be
giving the you know giving them the
medicine they might end up doing
something for you
later on because they're still going to
be alive if you end up killing them
they're not going to be around anymore
and you might have to fight somebody
else or be in a larger type of situation
so when you end up going into each type
of a scenario
where something might happen you're
going to want to make sure you take a
moment to think about that
now there's also going to be time where
you're going to have to do things
quicker where
there's just one part in the video when
you're gonna end up seeing is that where
i'm gonna be fighting somebody over and
over and over again because i'm dying
but eventually i realized that if i
throw my dagger
hit the guy and actually get the aggro
instead of him fighting the other person
that other person is actually going to
do something for us later on
so you have to kind of learn and pick
your battles throughout the whole entire
time
you're making this game and like i said
the combat
makes it really really interesting and a
different
depthness to the game itself now
there's a bunch of different what i
would consider puzzles which are going
to be you
running through different parts of the
caverns to
learn where you're gonna have to go pick
this up go here and do this
go here and do that while you're doing
that you might find
traps now there's gonna be like i wanted
to put another clip in there of
one of the simpler chaps in the
beginning where you're gonna have to
learn how to get past the trap
so you don't instantly die if you
end up going through this trap over and
over and over again you're gonna learn
you know what you're gonna wanna do and
not do and
for instance it took me a couple of
tries and i wanted to
you know make sure i did this so i
actually
had problems at one point and i said to
myself
oh my god what am i gonna do how how i
can't kill this one guy
and i was talking to lord cognito and
cognito tells me he goes
you do know that you can lower the
difficulty and i was like you can lower
the difficulty
so i ended up lowering the difficulty
and i ended up getting past that
character and that's
how i ended up beating the game which
was not much farther after that
but it ends up being that
you can end up taking your time and
learning a lot
and how beautiful the artwork is and the
combat
is and i will say that the creatures you
end up fighting
are very very ingeniously drawn and
beautifully animated the combat system
is
very very well done i would definitely
say
if you have the time like i said go
download this game and definitely take
it and and you know go into game pass
download it buy it on steam do wherever
you can find it
please go check it out once again this
is from two ton
studios and this is unto the end please
go check them out
thank you very much now remember if you
have to check
anything for gaming make sure you go to
lords of gaming.net where you can find
all your gaming
and hardware news in addition to that
make sure you go and check the iron
lords podcast
on sundays and this is pete also knows
now though
here to give you this video thank you
and have a great day
okay
good
hmm
um
oh
come on
uh
come on
ugh
come on
um
uh hmm
hmm
hmm
okay
oh
foreign
[Music]
you